[Musik]
die nächste pandemie könnte uns schon in
wenigen jahren erreichen befürchten
gesundheitsexperten sie raten daher zu
erstens mehr umwelt- klima- und
tierschutz
zweitens zum ausbau der präventiven
forschung
drittens zu mehr globaler zusammenarbeit
und viertens zu höheren investitionen
jedes jahr gehen laut global forest
lodge rund 300.000 quadratkilometer wald
verloren
die fläche italiens außerdem wird immer
mehr boden versiegelt dadurch kommen uns
viele tierarten und natürlich nah
außerdem in der folge des klimawandels
gibt es mehr dürreperioden in ganz
subsahara-afrika ersetzen deshalb pharma
im großen stil kühe und ziegen durch
dromedare die sind robuster aber eben
auch träger eines gefährlichen virus
tiere sind so 75 prozent der
ausgangspunkt aller neu auftretenden
infektionskrankheiten zu losen die von
wild nutz oder haustieren auf den
menschen überspringen und folgen schwere
krankheiten auslösen
tollwut skates und das zita virus einige
weitere bekannte beispiele
überall wo die natürlichen barrieren
zwischen tieren und menschen schwinden
wächst die gefahr
so auch auf tier märkten hier kommen
spezies miteinander in berührung die
sich in der natur nie begegnet wären
erreger können auf andere tierarten
überspringen und in der folge auch
menschen infizieren
aber auch die hoch industrialisierte
welt mit massentierhaltung ist anfällig
für zoologische solchen wie schweine und
vogelgrippe eine nachhaltige
viehwirtschaft intakte ökosysteme
rückzugsräume und schutzgebiete können
pandemien verhindern
außerdem müssen unter anderem die tier
märkte als ein ausgangspunkt für neue
infektionskrankheiten besser überwacht
werden
[Musik]
nach schätzungen gibt es rund 1,7
millionen unbekannte viren in der
tierwelt gut die hälfte von ihnen könnte
auf den menschen übertragbar sein
die internationale initiative cpi
unterstützt global die entwicklung von
impfstoffen gegen gefährliche erreger
außerdem gibt es die globe eine
initiative die internationale forschungs
förderer zusammenbringt um im falle von
epidemien schnell und unkompliziert
erkenntnisse bündeln zu können
[Musik]
auch deutschland unterstützt diese
initiativen sowohl finanziell als auch
mit forschung beim deutschen zentrum für
infektionsforschung liegt ein
schwerpunkt zb auf coronaviren hier wird
aktuell natürlich viel zu saas koch 2
geforscht aber auch das gefährliche
meeres corona virus steht im fokus neben
der entwicklung von impfstoffen läuft
auch die forschung für antivirale
medikamente auf hochtouren
zurück zur globalen prävention
hochrisiko bereichen wie tier märkten
und massentierhaltung muss besondere
aufmerksamkeit zuteil werden
das bedeutet man benötigt zum beispiel
in ländern mit tier märkten auch
entsprechend ausgestattete labore
arzneien werden mittlerweile auch
präventiv entwickelt forscherteams
benutzen künstliche intelligenz auch um
vorherzusagen welche arten von erregern
gefährlich werden könnten
und es sollten mehr so genannte penrose
weg scenes also breiter wirken der
impfstoffe entwickelt werden wie zb
gegen ganze virus familien effektiv sind
mutationen inklusive
die präventive forschung ist also extrem
wichtig auch wenn sie hohe kosten
verursacht sie muss über staatlich
koordiniert werden damit die
erkenntnisse möglichst schnell möglichst
vielen zur verfügung stehen die
weltgesundheitsorganisation who ist als
übergeordnete institution zuständig aber
die whu ist angeschlagen
finanziell und politisch von denen etwa
5,8 milliarden us dollar für den
haushalt 2020 21 stammt nur etwa ein
fünftel aus den pflichtbeiträgen der
mitgliedsstaaten
der rest sind freiwillige leistungen der
länder und vor allem spenden und diese
spenden sind meistens zweckgebunden
ein großer teil des geldes steht der whu
also nicht zur freien verfügung
außerdem sind alle maßnahmen und
anordnungen der whu grundsätzlich nur
empfehlungen und damit nicht bindend und
selbst bei epidemien mit pandemie
potenzial behält das betroffene land die
federführung
die whu musste china für
ursachenforschung und krisen
unterstützung in sachen saß kopf zwei
sozusagen um einlass bitten
die mitgliedstaaten müssen also die whu
durch entsprechende zahlungen
unabhängiger und an epidemischen
hotspots handlungsfähig machen
und die whu muss ein effektives globales
forschungs und frühwarnsystem für
gefährliche infektionskrankheiten
aufbauen
[Musik]
das alles kostet viel geld
im jahr 2009 10 wurden weltweit
geschätzt 374 millionen us-dollar für
die prävention von pandemien ausgegeben
gebraucht wird das 70 fache rund 26
milliarden hat die internationale
arbeitsgruppe prävention von weltbank
und bücher errechnet
klingt viel wären aber nur rund zwei
prozent der geschätzten gesamtkosten der
kogit 19 pandemie
wenn die weltgemeinschaft also mehr
investiert in umwelt- klima- und
tierschutz in präventive forschung und
in bessere globale zusammenarbeit ist
die menschheit für die nächste pandemie
besser gewappnet
alle quellen zu diesem video findet ihr
unten in der infobox
[Musik]